now to say that there's a separation of
church and state and that the state is
not to infringe on the free exercise of
religion and is not to establish any
religion is in effect you declare that
that the state the American state is not
a Christian state the American people
may be but the state is not a Christian
state but it's not a Jewish state it's
not it there's no there's no name of
religion that qualifies the American
state so when people say America is a
Christian nation what you got to do is
try to disambiguate it are you talking
about the people or are you talking
about the political structure I think
it's important to realize that there's a
second way in which the formation of the
American state at the in the you know
late 1700 represented a continuation
there had been a long up let me start
definitely fundamental to the creation
of the American state is the appeal to
natural rights of citizens natural
rights of citizens against the state and
hence we get a bill of rights and so
forth now it's often a Sanders story
about the formation of the idea of
natural rights is that it comes out of
the Enlightenment so that it emerges
that about the same time as the American
state we've got we've got really good
books of the last 15 years which show
that that's just a Monsta Blee false
it's just a falsehood the idea of
natural rights becomes articulate with
the Canon lawyers and in central europe
in the 1100s and it becomes a long
tradition and what the Founding Fathers
are doing is not inventing something
brand new here but they're employing
employing this long tradition of natural
rights in in new ways so that's the
second kind of continuity that's just
sort of adding on to the a little note
to your question but does that do it